Hmm.
If you hold something sacred,
then your team's circles around it and
it's only those who circled around with
you and sometimes literally circled
around like Muslims at prayer in Mecca,
they literally circle the kebabs.
Circling is a very primitive,
ancient.
It feels right to circle something,
but even if even if you do it
symbolically or you all bow at the same
time that binds you together,
children do that with their mothers when
they,
when they engage in exploratory behavior
like,
well they use their mother as a center
of the world and children differ in the
degree to which they'll move outward
from their mothers.
So they move out until they,
they,
they trip over their uncertainty
threshold.
Neat.
Is it a distance,
like it's a district that is.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And so,
so the more exploratory kids who are
lower negative emotion will go out
farther before they come back to their
mother.
So the mother is the center and you know
that that would be associated
symbolically with the idea of the center
has a motherland or potentially as a
father like that's right.
That makes sense.
So this way that we're,
we're incredibly symbolic creatures.
We're not just out to make as much money
as we can.
Where's the symbolic and social
creatures and this psychology of
sanctity or purity has become really
important,
not just on the right.
It's always been important for
especially religious conservatives were
beginning to see it even on the campus
left,
and this is why I think we see some of
the odd things we see on campus that the
campus must be kept as a sacred and pure
space.
One of the things that really alarms me
about what's happened on campus and last
couple of years is that the older idea
we had that it's a place for contesting
ideas.
It's A.
It's a zone of enormous choice.
People can take what courses they want,
say what they want.
It's kind of a wonderful free for all
with some with norms of respect.
It's now becoming much more of a
religious zone where the perimeter of
the campus is the boundaries and within
it they're almost their blasphemy laws
basically.
And I really started noticing this.
When you look at the videos of the
Middlebury,
a protest when Charles Murray spoke at
Middlebury and as,
as everybody knows,
he was shouted down so the students are
chanting and they're chanting in unison
and it seems like a religious revival
meeting and they're swaying and they're
saying they're sacred,
you know,
racist,
sexist,
antigay,
Charles Murray go away.
It's like a ritual incantation.
Um,
so that all the space is safe and it's
safe and maternal.
Not yet.
So far all this happening is they're
binding together.
They're moving and you know,
synchronous movement and call and
response.
So it's using a lot of tropes from
religion and religious worship.
But here's the cool thing,
when the administrator,
I forget who it is,
comes on to say,
okay,
we have moved,
we're moving the talk.
And then you hear a couple of people
screaming up off campus off campus and
he says to another location on campus
and there's like,
oh no,
no,
because you know,
no one had to go to this talk.
So everyone could have just stayed at
home and the students did succeed in
shutting down to venues.
They could have declared victory,
but it's not a full victory unless he is
physically off the campus.
We can't have him speaking on campus
because that defiles us.
That pollutes us.
We must shut that down.
And that's where I started saying,
wow,
this is like full blown psychology of
religion,
Durkheim,
sanctity,
purity blast for me.
And that I think,
you know,
that doesn't describe most students,
but that describes this sort of the
core.
Those who who really have their identity
is wrapped up in this movement.